now labour have won back the red bull
seat of wakefield from the conservatives
in last night's by-election with a
majority of almost five thousand nhs
worker simon lightwood will now
represent the west yorkshire city and
the commons labour leader sakir stama
has said that the vote shows the country
in his words has lost confidence in the
tories well we can speak now to the
shadow leveling up secretary lisa nandy
lisa mandy good afternoon to you a red
brick back in the wall for wakefield
i think what's really significant for us
about this result is we obviously had a
great candidate and we ran a great
campaign
and there was a lot of distaste for the
prime minister that was reflected to us
on the doorsteps but
this is our best result in wakefield
since 2001 it's our best ever result on
current boundaries more than a 12 swing
which if replicated across the country
will put labour on course to form a
majority government of course we're not
complacent we'll go out and fight for
every vote as we did in wakefield come
the next election but this is a big
boost to us because
we didn't just see people turning away
from the tories we also felt very much a
mood on the ground i felt it yesterday
when i was knocking on doors that people
were looking to labor again and in many
instances they were saying we really
like what we see we think this is a
party that will back us and deliver for
us in government in a way that the
tories just haven't done
well 12 swing you say it is it is
significant but that was the same swing
we saw uh when labour won it back under
corbyn
well we we've had a storming result
there's just no way around it we were
quietly confident we weren't complacent
you should have seen the effort
yesterday there were just teams out
trying to get people to um to come out
and vote but crucially what we were
finding was that people people often had
already gone and done it they they liked
simon they liked his message but most of
all i think they just felt increasingly
that the country can't go on with a
government that doesn't back it or
support it most people now are dealing
with the cost of living crisis most
families and businesses struggling to
make ends meet and they'd heard things
like the campaign that we led for the
windfall tax they'd heard us even on
issues like the bus and rail strikes
where the tories have very much tried to
to blame labour for it and they'd heard
us saying get round the table and sort
this out and back people who want to get
to work and who run our railways and
people were responding to that message
so if i were the tourists i would be
worried about this result not just
because of boris johnson's deep on
popularity but because i think there is
genuinely a feeling that this is a
government that just simply isn't
working yeah but given all the you know
the trail of uh
what many of the electric view to be
disasters under boris johnson's
government um the tories lost twice as
many votes as labour gained in that
by-election it could have gone better
well i mean of course every election can
go better but it's hard to see how we
could have imagined a better result than
this especially three years ago when we
had this very painful break
with people who'd voted labour all their
lives through successive generations and
felt that they couldn't do again when
that happened and we lost seats like
wakefield and knew that it was painful
but i also wondered if it was permanent
what we saw this this time was not just
a lot of people saying we can't vote for
the tories but we did see people coming
back to us and i was hearing that on the
doors everywhere that i went people
did have a real sense that labour is
rooting for them and that we've got
ideas that will help to solve the very
real problems that they've got i think
for me this is very much a sign that
people are looking not just for an
opposition to this government but for an
alternative and where we've been putting
forward alternatives such as getting
around the table and sorting out the
rail strikes such as the windfall tax
and getting money back into people's
pockets and trying to create growth in
the economy that's what people have
responded to and so you can expect to
see a lot more from us on that over the
coming months so what is the labour
party strategy uh in the run-up to the
next
general election now we can see the
potency of tactical voting there might
we see some electoral pacts
well we we didn't have an electoral pact
in this election and nor would we people
vote with their feet they decide what
they want to do and i think you know
people wanting to get rid of boris
johnson was clearly a big driver in both
of these by-elections but there was more
than that as well there were people
coming back to labor they weren't just
looking at us again they were coming
back to us and having vowed not to do so
three years ago
and that is that is a big moment for the
labour party and for the labour movement
they've heard that we've dealt with some
of the issues that were rightly costing
us votes at the last general election i
think there is a feeling that we've you
know we've we've worked very hard to try
and repair that relationship and that
we're going to deliver for them when we
say that we're going to invest 28
billion a year every year over a decade
to get good jobs back into places like
wakefield and other parts of the north
and the midlands i think people really
do respond to that they believe that
we're rooting for them and that we're
coming up with the plans and the ideas
to support them you know wakefield
yesterday was a really you know it's
difficult there's a bus strike on
there's a rail strike on
people really struggling to get out but
they came out in order to show that they
think things can be different and we're
determined to be the party that gives
voice to that so
may i ask that may i ask um is
kierstarma the man to win a general
election the most recent yougov poll uh
finds that 51 percent of adults say he
is doing badly as labour leader and very
tellingly i think 19 don't know
well you know he's became leader in the
middle of a pandemic and we've been
we've been playing catch-up ever since
but i think this is really a significant
moment for us because
people were very much responding to
labour not just voting against the
conservatives and of course we'd never
be complacent about that but the joke
with boris johnson really is starting to
wear thin things that people thought
were funny about him the fact that he
makes these big bold claims and doesn't
really deliver that he mucks around when
um you know makes jokes and wise cracks
and likes the political knockabout i
think people have had enough of that
actually they're looking for serious
politicians for serious times and i
think there is very much a sense that
kierstama is a serious credible
politician who will do what he says he
will do and that you can trust him at
his word
you mentioned you mentioned the strikes
that are paralyzing the country at the
moment very pertinently um he's got a
bit of a problem with leadership there
hasn't he because he's told that his
party uh none of you are going to go and
join the picket line and yet some of his
own front benchers did so
well look i mean i don't think he's got
a problem with leadership at all because
he's been out as has louise hague our
shadow transport secretary and many
others making the case that rail workers
have been doing their jobs they have
been trying to keep our railways going
through the pandemic they've been
fighting for better safety and security
on the railways and a fair deal
for living standards the public are
trying to do their jobs they're trying
to get to work in the face of these
crippling devastating strikes and what
we're doing as a labour party is our job
which is exerting maximum pressure on
the government in parliament and
elsewhere and in wakefield yesterday to
say get round the table and sort this
out because you're the only people who
can that's us doing our job that's the
public doing their job now we need the
government to start doing their job